اذا نلقي الان نظره على المحكمه الجرائيه
الدوليه ومقرها في مدينه لاهاي بهولندا
ونتوقف عند اهم اختصاصات هذه المحكمه
تاسست هذه المحكمه بصفه قانونيه في الاول
من يوليو تموز عام 2002 بموجب ميثاق روما
وميثاق روما وافقت عليه 120 دوله في
اجتماع للجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده في
ايطاليا عام
لكل سبع دول عرضت لكن سبع دول عرضت الفكره
حينها بينما امتنعت احدى وعشرون دوله عن
التصويت تختص المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه في
متابعه الافراد المتهمين بجرائم الاباده
الجماعيه والجرائم الحرب والجرائم ضدها
الانسانيه وتعتبر مكمله للقضاء الوطني
للدول الاعضاء فيها وتمثل وتمثل ايضا
المال عندما تكون هذه المحاكم غير قادره
على تحقيق مع المتهمين في الجرائم
المذكوره او لا تريد ذلك
تاريخيا اصدرت المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
عشرات مذكرات الاعتقال في حق قاده سياسيين
ووزراء وزعماء حركات مسلحه نستعرض ابرز
قاده الدول الذين شملتهم هذه المذكرات فقد
صدرت في حق الرئيس السوداني عمر البشير
مذكره
اعتقالاهما في عام
والثانيه في العام 2010 كما صدرت مذكره
اعتقال في حق الزعيم الليبيا الراحل معمر
القذافي وذلك في يونيو من عام 2011 بعد
اندلاع الثوره ضده واغلقت القضيه في
نوفمبر 2011 بعد وفاته وشملت مذكرات
التوقيف ايضا الرئيس السابق لكوت ديفوار
في عام 2011 وقد تعرض للاعتقال فعلا وخضع
للمحكمه ثم ها هي المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوريه تصدر مذكره اعت قال في حق الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين في السابع عشر من
هذا الشهر الجاري على خلفيه حرب اوكرانيا